aliu you're
up damn aliu isn't that picture
Haram you might not be a muslim
okay I you you there going once going
twice
KCK all
right let's go ahead and bring up
let's bring up
Hamza Hamza what's up uh wait can you
hear me I can hear you just fine why'd
you change your
name well I didn't change my name you do
your name is something here but on your
display it's something
else no I'm just
hzo so your name is not
Amir
no got it so why does it say Amir no
that's just my
email just your email yeah got take care
yourself what do you
want
sketch uh this guy's kosher that's why I
came up I'm not
gonna what one
second he he's actually a Seeker he's 17
years
old he's very open he's a very
respectful young man I told them to come
to you so I'm going to leave but very
respectful young man very open he's a
class act his name is something say he
comes to my channel I told him come to
you so he's on the door so try to win
him by the way I sent you a clip I just
did it Muslim metaphysician came out
saying he pretty much abandoned the
debate because he thought Daniel was
gonna get slaughtered he just came out
saying they got Slaughter in our debate
I did as a short did you really yeah
yeah I sent you it so you want to play
it he came out he he admits he ran from
the debate because he thought Dan was
going to get
slaughtered so to Christ work with hza
guys pray for hza he's a very respectful
young man he's 17 years old love this
kid yeah come back if you're if you're
listening my bad man no he's coach his
name is s I told him to come he's 17 so
guys Lord willing I'll I'll be playing
that clip later in my stream later so
I'll see you brother take care of this
guy he's on the door all right take care
soon yeah uh Hamza come back my bad man
you know I got to be hyper alert we've
been getting a lot of trolls lately so I
just got to be hyper alert man so come
on come on back we can talk my bad
Hamza come on through all right so in
the meantime let's go ahead and have a
little watch party that Sam
mentioned um let's check this out
Samuel let me go to my uh my YouTube
let's go to my uh
let's go to my history let's see what
let's see what he talking about
man all right let's see what he's
talking
about
M exactly what's gonna happen and they
got slayed Faithfully on Trinity versus
exactly what's going to happen and they
Ted and I will openly state that and I
don't care if scam shiman or any of
these clowns clip it because it's the
reality and I'm stating it as a fact now
this is why I did not appear on the
fresh and fit debate I said listen if
you don't want to defend e openly and
answer these questions honestly then I'm
out of the debate you can find another
partner okay but I warnant him if he
does this strategy it's not going to
work so
I
yo so look at that ladies and
gentlemen so look and and this is why
this is important actually because we
were actually under the
impression that he didn't join the
debate because his internet was not
working isn't that right Sam if you're
still here can you confirm this that he
didn't join the debate he said he wasn't
joining the debate because his internet
was not working that's what he that was
his official message to the media
right we saw it he was supposed to be in
uh in Morocco and yes he was in Morocco
and his internet was not working so
therefore he couldn't make the debate
they had to get someone else but here he
comes clean and says you know what
forget it forget all that the reason why
I didn't come is because they wasn't
going to deal with these topics honestly
and defend the aita honestly and they
were going to use tactics that were
going to get them destroyed and they got
destroyed on the on on this he didn't
want to be a part of that destruction so
really he ran away from the debate at
first he told us it was because he had
bad
connection that's what he told the
masses but now here we got the truth
let's see it one more time one more time
I like this one last time exactly what's
gonna happen and they got slayed
Faithfully on Trinity versus Ted and I
will openly state that and I don't care
if scam shimul or any of these clowns
clip it because it's the reality and I'm
stating it as a fact oh oh we we we G
clip it we we we we GNA clip it man run
one one more time man one more time one
one more time what's gonna happen and
they got slayed Faithfully on Trinity
versus Ted and I will openly state that
and I don't care if scam shiman or any
of these clowns clip it because it's the
reality and I'm stating it as a fact now
this is why I as a
fact Faithfully Faithfully you guys got
Faithfully
utterly factually destroyed we oh we we
clipping this
m we we clipping this ain't
we and and you know Daniel can't resist
he's going to respond it's just going to
create more shot more sh shot more Shuba
hot man more Shuba hot good stuff good
stuff thanks for that little nugget Sam
appreciate it all right sorry yeah sorry
about that Hamza you're back yeah I'm
back all right welcome back man welcome
back welcome back man you uh you gotta
be pretty cool if Sam talks well about
you man wait what I said you got to be
pretty cool
told you about me yeah he came up and he
said you know hey he's he's a cool guy
young he's respectful you know I told
him to come to you so yeah yeah so
welcome man welcome did you have um you
have any questions or I just have one
question yeah I know you probably said
this many times but I just want to hear
it because I'm trying to gain knowledge
to be honest yeah it's about the
Divine
incarnation of Dy Jesus is basically if
if God is all powerful and
transcended how can he become like human
and experience like human
limitations yeah okay good question so
one it's not we got to understand this
so
far you can hear me wait wait I'm not
oh you okay go go
ahead how does he like align with the
concept of like of God and being Eternal
and
unchanging yes okay now you finished now
yeah I'm finished there you can go right
good so so rep's question is um how can
God um you know limit himself to human
limitations and also uh if he's taking
on a human nature how does that coincide
with the the idea that God is unchanging
God doesn't change so yeah if we say
that he took on a human nature are we
saying that God changed okay so now
we're about to answer this okay okay so
number one let me work backwards so no
we're not saying that God took on a
change and here's why it's because with
the hypostatic Union we're saying that
Jesus Took on another nature to himself
so it's not that divine nature like
stopped being Divine and became human no
it's just that now he he he he has added
on a human nature to himself to his
person person of Christ so now the
person of Christ Jesus he has two
Natures a fully divine nature and a
fully human nature so they're both
United in the person of Christ they
don't mix the the divine nature doesn't
become less Divine because of this or
the human nature doesn't become you know
Divine now or God no it's just it's he
has a divine nature he's fully Divine
fully human they're both United in the
person of Christ so the divine nature
doesn't
change okay so you're saying that like
um the father he puts his like Divine
his nature into like a human body but
but like nothing
changes we're we're we're saying that
the Sun the the sun takes on a a human
nature he feels it like like almost like
a hand feels a glove right and also the
Bible call the Bible you know reckons
this to like a veil he veils himself in
flesh right so Veil is his the flesh is
his covering and he takes on the human
nature and and so that's what's that's
what's taking place it's not that his
divine nature now changes and becomes
human that's not what's happening okay
understood yeah um now now to answer
your question about limitations right
about him freely limiting himself let me
just let me just give you a verse in the
Bible to answer this and we'll we'll
break it down is that okay yeah
understood all right cool cool cool so
here's the book of Philippians chapter 2
so actually one of my favorite
passages
and let me stop sharing full screen I've
heard I've heard about you before I
think you debated with Shake
man before yeah man yep I had a yep had
had a couple run-ins with my best
pal ibben fibon
yeah you're like the only person I guess
known that has like really like I guess
like the went on level with shik
Osman terms of in terms
of terms of debate
yeah you're like the one that gave him a
challenge let's say there's a reason why
before he met logic he was always at at
the at the park then suddenly afterwards
he went on a world tour going everywhere
logic
wasn't I I I don't know it could be like
there's a correlation to it I'm just you
know seeing something that isn't there
but as far as I know shikma wasn't
traveling the world before until after
he met logic that's what I got to say
and is it
is there are many other
good all right so let's let's check this
verse out now right about limiting
himself yeah so this verse right here
this passage is talking about the
mindset of humility having the humble
mindset right and so it says in verse
four Let each of you right here Let each
of you not look um only to his own
interests but also to the interests of
others have this mind among yourselves
which is yours in Christ Jesus who
though he was in the form of God right
did not count equality with God a thing
to be grasp or something to be held onto
right he didn't have to hold onto it
desperately but emptied himself made
himself of no reputation by so emptied
himself by taking the form of a servant
being born in the likeness of men so
what does he do he humbles himself right
it says and being found in human form he
humbled himself by becoming obedient to
the point of death even death on a cross
so what is happening here is that Jesus
even though he has the nature of God he
humbles himself and takes the form of a
to be humble humble yes exactly so it's
not that he loses his power that's not
what happened he doesn't lose his power
but he just takes the position of a
humble servant
right that's that's what takes place
there so he he freely you know you know
withholds himself he withholds his glory
he withholds his power and you know what
and truly lives amongst us as a human
right like he wasn't shining like a like
the bright Sun you know or you know
flying everywhere or teleporting like he
could have been but he walked places you
know he you know rode a donkey you know
what I'm saying he you know teed the
ground you know he was you know that's
you know he humbled himself and really
was human does that make
sense yeah so so Jesus he wanted to be
like I guess like closer with humans if
that makes sense he
want it's not that he wanted to be
closer with humans that that's not
purpose of him doing that the the
purpose of him humbling himself and
becoming say that
again I know it's not like that I'm
trying to explain it but like
difficult that's
okay yeah what I was saying is is that
um it's not that he's doing this to be
closer to humanity like because he
doesn't need to do that to be closer to
humanity what's happening is is that
human beings human kind we are under the
wrath of God because we have sinned
against him God is holy God is just and
we have to you know answer for our our
sin against God our crimes we have to be
punished
but God loves us now the the punishment
for sin the Wage of Sin according to
God's law is death it's death right and
the Torah says this it says that the the
blood is the the way that you atone for
your sins it's the atonement of sins is
in the blood right but God loves us he
wants us to live He's merciful he's
loving as well as much as he is
righteous he's also loving so because
he's righteous and holy and just he
cannot just let our sin go sin has to be
punished but also because he's loving
and
merciful um he gives us his grace so we
need a situation where God is both both
merciful and he's just at the same time
where he doesn't sacrifice one the other
yeah it balance things
out exactly so the balance is is that
God is merciful and that he punishes sin
he doesn't let it go right so I'm sorry
he's just in that he's just in that he
punishes sin he does not let it go he's
merciful in that he takes on the sin
himself so that we don't have to so he
takes on a human form and him in human
form he represents mankind now so now
he's our representative he can take our
place because he's perfect he's holy and
he represents Mankind and so the the the
sins of man can be placed on him and be
rightfully dealt
with so that's why he humbled himself to
and was born in human in human form
okay
okay now now you get it yeah so it's not
it's not for him to be closer to us
because he already is but it's for us to
get closer to him him to free us so that
we can be closer to him because we're
sin FR we're we're forgiven we have his
grace also Hamza just another
interesting point uh on this topic is uh
maybe you're asking yourself okay fine
why is all this stuff necessary in the
first place so if I had to like sum this
up I'm taking this from something a
conversation that I had with uh with Sig
a little while ago actually and you know
how the idea is that oh Islam means
submission Islam is about submission if
we had to give ourselves a tagline for
Christianity it would be that
Christianity is about
perfection so you and I can tell that
the world that we live in is very far
from perfect yes there are good people
who walk around and do good things like
gift of Charity but there are also
people who walk around doing bad things
uh people who are just born into
scenarios that don't give them a fa fair
chance in life they're born and then
suddenly their parents die or they're
born in a place where their parents
don't care for them so something is
fundamentally broken with the world as
well as the people who live on the world
so what hope do we have that things will
get better for everybody at some
stage left to our own power we have no
hope we'll just carry on living in the
same cycle that we live in if if
everyone's behaving well maybe even a
hurricane can happen and people can
still die and suffer so there has to be
a point where everything the natural
disasters the human immorality at some
point stops it comes to an end and then
we can finally have peace so that
unfortunately isn't possible in the
world that we currently live in but in
what Jesus does what he shows us is a
blueprint for how we can also be like
him AKA
perfect and the reason why he has come
here is to fix that Brokenness that we
have in our lives and in our reality and
only by believing in him accepting him
and then walking in his tenants can we
when we are resurrected finally be
perfect like he is and so there'll be no
more need for death disease Decay that's
the reason behind it so ultimately what
is our faith about our faith is about
perfection that's only achieved
through
Christ if that makes
sense
yeah yeah so I hope that uh that may
have helped you um and you know with
your question on you know Jesus taking
another nature why he took on human
nature and what it means that he you
know humbles himself or limits himself I
hope that that that we were able to help
you out today
man no no it did I understood that
perfect perfect now now you're so you're
you're yourself you're you're a Muslim
is that
right yeah I'm Muslim what what is uh
what's keeping you as a
Muslim well I was I was born Muslim into
a Muslim family
mhm I see so grew so grew up in it
basically you're you're you're Muslim by
by culture straight
up Muslim
house and so have you just recently
taken an interest in to Christianity
like what what what Christians
believe like
Rec a few years ago I have seen like I
guess some debates here and there but I
wasn't really interested but then now I
wanted to like you know just like seek
knowledge or understand
the I see I see um so let let me ask you
this then um if if you were to
see like I because I ask this to people
all the time about truth we we have to
cherish truth we have to submit to truth
whatever the truth is regardless of what
our prior belief was would you agree
with
that yeah yeah that despite like it
despite what I believe if what if if the
truth contradicts what I believe then I
have to submit to the truth I have to
leave my old beliefs and submit to the
truth um and that's what I just try to
invite all the Muslims that I talk to is
as you're investigating this to do this
with the purpose of wanting the truth
and being willing to submit to it once
you've once you found it you know
regardless of if it goes against what
you you know grew up with or you know
that's what's most important because
we're talking about where you're going
to spend eternity right Paradise or hell
and we all want paradise and the truth
depends on
that right so one thing that I like to
go over with Muslims is the consistent
message of the prophets we all uh we all
believe that the prophets all taught the
same message and they backed each other
up especially in Islam you believe that
right
yeah all right and so that's that's what
we hold to as well in Christianity I
mean the a large reason why we believe
that Jesus is the Messiah is because the
prophets foretold us about him the
prophets told us about about the Messiah
to come matter of fact that was that was
one of the proofs that Jesus said you
know he said if you would have believed
Moses you would have believed me because
Moses wrote about about me he said
Isaiah wrote about me you know Zechariah
Malachi they wrote about me right and so
he said that he is fulfilling what the
prophets and the law the Torah and the
Psalms David what they have all talked
about so that right there is huge and
it's important what did all the prophets
say and then we can know the truth they
have to be consistent if there's
somebody that's out of line with the
prophets then we can see that that
person is is actually false and we could
throw them to the Wayside
right yeah so this is what I want to
show you man really quick I want to show
you this we're going to see what did the
prophets
teach what was their consistent message
it's it's actually pretty we won't be
long it'll be it'll be quick
okay all right guys by the way as I get
these verses up make sure you guys hit
the like
button make sure you guys guys hit the
like button make sure you subscribe if
you haven't done that already guys I
like that we're in the algorithm got
2200 people watching okay so let's go
ahead and see what the prophets
say let's see what the prophets say so
I'm gonna show you Isaiah prophet
Isaiah okay and I'm gonna read a couple
of these verses have you SE have you
seen this before uh no no okay so we're
going to read uh the whole chapter is is
12 verses we're not going to read the
whole thing I'll just show you some of
the key ones
okay we'll read verse 3- six three 3 to
six it
says he was despised and rejected by Men
A Man of Sorrows and acquainted with
grief and as one from whom men hide
their faces he was despised and we
esteemed him not surely he has borne our
griefs and carried our sorrows yet we
esteemed him stricken Smitten by God and
icted but he was pierced for our
transgressions he was crushed for our
iniquities upon him was the chastisement
that means punishment that brought us
peace and with his wounds we are healed
all we like sheep have gone astray we
have turned everyone to his own way and
the lord has laid on him the iniquity of
us all iniquity is sin so God placed on
him the sins of of us all and he was
pierced for our
transgressions just off of just off of
off of a guess who does this sound like
to
you Jesus I would agree man you're
absolutely right it's talking about
Jesus here now the fascinating thing
about this is that this is written 700
years before Jesus is
born 700 years
that's
Isaiah that's Isaiah talking about what
happens to Jesus his crucifixion and him
taking on the sins of the world what
about David let's go to the zabor the
Psalms and watch
this the psalm first starts off with my
God my God why have you forsaken me are
those words
familiar I don't know I don't know too
much about David if I'm being honest oh
no it's good it's all good matter of
fact this is actually what Jesus said on
the cross he said my God my God why have
you forsaken me let's actually I think I
think I've seen those words before yeah
yeah you seen that before so this is so
Jesus was actually quoting Psalm 22 this
is what he's quoting this is where it
originates my God my God why have you
forsaken me so when Jesus is on the
cross this is what he says now when we
read Psalm 22 we actually see something
fascinating about what happens to this
person
why are you so far from saving me from
the words of my groaning oh my God I Cry
by day but you do not you do not answer
by night but I find No Rest yet You Are
Holy enthroned on the Praises of Israel
right let's just scroll down a little
bit he says but I am a worm and not a
man scorned by mankind and despised by
the people all who see me mock me they
make mouths at me and they wag their
heads he trusts in the Lord let him
deliver him let him rescue him for he
Delights in him which is exactly what
was happening to Jesus on the cross they
were mocking him when he was hanging on
the cross they would say why doesn't he
come down save yourself you're the Son
of God let God save you right they put
the The Thorn on his head is all in it
yep they put the thorns on his head
exactly now let's scroll down just a
little bit further as we're seeing
this says verse 14 I am poured out like
water
and all my bones are out of joint my
heart is like Wax it is melted within my
breast it means it's hard for him to
breathe he's suffocating my strength is
dried up like a pots herd and my tongue
sticks to my jaws you lay me in the dust
of death for dogs Encompass me a company
of evildoers encircles me and here it is
they have pierced my hands and my
feet wow
this is s this is David writing this but
guess what this didn't happen to David
none of this didn't happen to
David who's who's it sound like he's
talking about as we already
know Jesus Christ he's talking about the
Messiah the suffering that he's going to
go through his crucifixion here you have
it clear they pierced my hands and my
feet what now this is a thousand years
before Jesus is born
a thousand yes the Psalms come a
thousand years before Jesus was born
prophet Isaiah which is the first one we
read he's 700 years before Jesus is
born so that's two for two we have we
have David Prophet David we got prophet
Isaiah both prophesying the crucifixtion
and the suffering of the Messiah for the
sins of the
world right and then also here if we
continue I can count all my bones they
stare and gloat over me they divide my
garments among them and for my clothing
they cast lots they were gambling over
his clothes this is in matter of fact
let's just see this in John 19 this is
what happens at the cross the Roman
soldiers they stripped him of his
clothes and they were gambling over
him let's read this really quick where
is this at
uh here it is verse 23 this is John
Chapter 19 Verse 23 when the soldiers
had crucified Jesus they took his
garments and divided them into four
parts one part for each Soldier also his
tunic but the tunic was seamless woven
in one piece from top to bottom so they
said to another let's not tear it but
cast lots for it to see whose it shall
be this was to fulfill the scripture
which says they divided my garments
among them and for my clothing they cast
lots that's exactly what we just read in
Psalm
22 so we have the piercing of his hands
and feet we have the gambling of his
clothes being pro prophesied foretold a
thousand years before it
happens crazy
right yeah let me show you another
one here we have let's go to the Torah
let's go to the
Torah let's go to Moses what he's what
he's
saying Genesis now so far we're seeing
one consistent message the crucifixion
of the Messiah the the Messiah is going
to suffer he's going to die for the sins
of the world
consistent let's go to
Moses now this is in the garden right
before Adam and Eve they get kicked out
the garden and so this is what God says
to the serpent serpent the the devil
right this is what he says yeah he says
God says I will put enity between you
and the woman between your Offspring and
her Offspring really the word is seed
your seed and her seed right okay he
shall bruise your head and you shall
bruise his
heel so it says that the seed of the
woman is going to crush the head of the
serpent while the serpent is going to
bruise his heal so the seed of the woman
is going to be bruised but let me ask
you this women don't have seed do they
they receive seed no right no so how how
in the world does a woman have seed what
woman had her own
seed uh
Eve no not Eve because Eve had Adam put
the seed in her right he they they slept
together and then she bore children
Mary that's right Mary Mary did not have
she was a virgin yet she had SE all
right boom so Mary this is talking about
the Virgin birth and her son her seed is
going to crush the Serpent's head while
at the same time his heel he he will be
bruised so we see in the Torah it
teaches the Messiah is going to be
bruised while also crushing the serpent
we see in the Psalms of David the
Messiah is going to be bruised he's
going to suffer be crucified right be
mocked by the people in Isaiah we see
the Messiah is going to be pierced for
our transgressions crushed for our
iniquities wounded to bring us healing
right and the Lord is going to lay on
him the sins of us
all all right let me just show you one
more so that's three we got Moses we got
David we got Isaiah let's go to
Zechariah Zachariah I'm telling you
you're gonna see this thread I could
show you a bunch but just for the sake
of time I'm only going to show you just
these few for the sake of time this is
Zechariah 12:10 now this is God speaking
Watch What God Says okay this is God he
says
okay he says I will pour out on the
House of David and the inhabitants of
Jerusalem a spirit of Grace and please
from mercy so God is going to be pouring
out his Spirit of Grace and please for
Mercy he's going to cause them to want
to repent why so that when they look on
me on him whom they have
pierced they shall mourn for him as One
Mourns for an only child and weep
bitterly over him as one weeps over a
firstborn so God says he's going to pour
out his Spirit of pleasing mercy so the
people of Jerusalem the Israelites the
Jews they're going to be crying for his
forgiveness pleading for Mercy because
they saw God they saw him the one whom
they
pierced who is this talking about the
one who they
pierced that they're feeling guilty of I
think that's
Jesus
Zachariah Isaiah Moses and David
all talk about the piercing the
suffering the crucifixion of the Messiah
to come all of them one consistent
message now to top it off let's finish
it with Jesus himself what does Jesus
say about all
this and then I'mma ask you a question
regarding this okay because this is
incredible so this is what Jesus says
and you could tell it's Jesus because
it's in red letters so Jesus is talking
to his disciples this is after he was
crucified and then he rose again and
some of his disciples are sad because
they're like man he died we believed he
was the Messiah right so Jesus appeared
to them and he
says these are my words that I spoke to
you while I was still with you that
everything written about me in the law
of Moses and the prophets and the Psalms
must be fulfilled we saw that so what
what is it that must be fulfilled hold
on let me put it all
right he said it it was in the
Scriptures it says then he opened their
minds to understand the scriptures and
said to them thus it is written that the
Christ should suffer and on the third
day rise from the
dead that's in the scripture that's what
we just saw we saw it in the law of
Moses in the Torah we saw it in the
prophets Isaiah Zechariah and we saw it
in the Psalms of David
and then we see it in the gospel that
the Messiah was supposed to suffer for
the sins of the world and rise
again so this is my question we see that
this is a cons consistent message right
they're all teaching the same thing
right sure over a span of of hundreds of
years and a thousand years span of all
this time they're all teaching the same
message in all these different
Generations here's my question Muhammad
comes along 6 years after Jesus and he
says n actually no Jesus was not
crucified he wasn't killed he's not your
savior for your sins it was just made to
appear
so he contradicts what the prophets have
all clearly taught including
Jesus so who do we go with do we go with
all the prophets who are teaching the
same consistent message over Generations
or do we go with the one who claims to
be a
prophet but contradicts what the
previous prophets taught who do we go
with
well
it's it's tough because Prophet Muhammad
s alaihi wasallam and all the other
previous prophets they all like like
thing he said like the same message
after after after after so it's it's
kind of difficult I think it's
easy if all the prophets are teaching
one
message but then another Prophet comes
or somebody who claims to be a prophet
and he comes with a message that
contradicts the prophets that came
before him who do you go
with I
mean I I guess you're right but I think
you need to like talk about this someone
who's more like knowledgeable than
me you said you need to talk to somebody
who's more knowledgeable no no you
because I'm not like that
knowledgeable oh no dude this I'm not
bringing this as a like a debate point
I'm just I'm just showing you like you
know just straight up just off of the
foundation that you and I have we both
agree that the prophets had to be
consistent right they had to teach one
message so when we clearly see that the
prophets are teaching one message if
there's somebody else that comes and
contradicts them then we can obviously
see that that person is a false
prophet it's that clear you know it's
not even a
question right this is how we can tell
this is how we
know
so for for for you I'm just I'm
presenting this to you like this is what
I said when you're presented with the
truth right and um you want to think of
course you got to you got think about it
if you want to think about it fine you
want to ponder on it no problem you know
I invite you to do that but what I'm
saying is is that when you think about
this and you meditate on this you ponder
about this that you submit to what the
truth is regardless of if it contradicts
or goes against what you personally
believe
period what so what I'm showing you is
is that this is clear evidence bro
easy clear-cut evidence of how you can
tell who has the true
message and that's the Baseline is the
consistency of the
prophets Muhammad is out of touch with
the prophets he contradicts them so you
can objectively clearly see that he's
not a true prophet of God because he
contradicted the revelation of God of
the
past okay so that that's all I wanted to
present to you
and I guess H my last point would be
like we could talk to somebody more
knowledgeable than you but unfortunately
that person wouldn't actually bother
addressing any of the verses that God
logic bought off what they'll do is
they're knowledgeable about how to
change the topic so actually I think
you're in a advantageous position
because you're honest you can actually
look at the verses that God logic
provided um to you for what they are and
yes while they are commonalities between
the things that prophets preach none of
them contradict each other so if you're
coming with the knowledge that prophets
spoke about one God that's cool but then
now when a prophet or someone who claims
to be a prophet speaks about one God but
then denies
the suffering of the Messiah then he's
not in touch with the total message that
previous prophets
bought
yeah so think about this man if Muhammad
is on a line with the prophets he's not
a true Prophet done and you line up with
the true prophets that teach the coming
of the Messiah who is God in the flesh
who takes on Humanity takes on human
flesh to take on the sins of the world
and offers you salvation and Redemption
without him you don't have Redemption
and you have to face God on Judgment Day
with your sins on you but with the
Messiah and your belief in him following
the message of the
prophets and you see the Messiah for who
he truly is as the prophets tell us he
is then the the same Grace can be
bestowed on
you same thing the same gift of mercy
and Grace can be bestowed on you but
without him you're going to still be
blemished and stained with your own sin
and you won't have salvation believing
in a false
prophet it's that
urgent you get what I'm saying it's it's
that
important yeah it's that
important so yeah if I were you I
wouldn't gamble on somebody who came and
contradicted what all the prophets
taught I wouldn't I wouldn't do that man
I wouldn't do
that I couldn't do
it
well thank you for telling me all of
this of course man please please do me a
favor when you when you're on on your
own time replay this back so that you
can see the verses again write them down
and uh you know pray about it talk about
it pray about it come back and if you
have more questions or want to talk some
more come back I'm here I'm I'm live
every Monday Wednesday and Friday I'm
always live told me
back good
good all right well this is good I we'll
close it here we're at the three- hour
mark appreciate you for coming man like
I said come back anytime I would love to
see you again okay understood
it's